for the first time ever you got one
fight night 17 on Prime Amazon Prime
this freaking Friday I'll be in Chicago
but have it on the Green Room uh I'm in
Chicago this Friday Saturday but
December 8th at 8:00 p.m. Eastern on
Prime Video Amazon Prime video you have
the one Championship will broadcast a
card in the US Prime Time where every
single fight will be in one Muay Thai
what's one Muay Tha I'm glad you asked
Fighters must engage constantly they
can't stall otherwise they get warnings
kind of like the pride days and then
it's Muay Thai and 4 o gloves all right
you get three three minute rounds so
it's not like this long drawn out thing
they have to engage it is action-packed
if you like fistic cuffs if you like to
see Knockouts by the most talented
people that can kick punch and elbow on
this freaking planet tune in Friday
night at 8:00 P.M Eastern